[Music]
hi guys in Brownville simply learn and
today I'm going to tell you how you can
become a successful leader scientist
before I begin let me give you an
example
share at home and you're bored and if
you like watching a TV show or a movie
then you get on Netflix you scroll
through all the TV shows and movies that
they offer then you recommended the
latest season of Deadwood because you
seem so similar we all enjoy building
shows on Netflix but do you actually
know how much of data science is used
along with Netflix Netflix analyzes the
user's behavior from hundreds of
different TV shows and movies to create
the best recommendations for everyone
they measure user engagement and
retention on various shows know
currently they're even applying advanced
metrics that include when you boss
rewind or fast word that's when you see
something really cool and you want to
watch it again what do you watch the
content for example some days you feel
like watching a comedy show sometimes
drama and so on when and why you leave
the content when you stop watching a
show why did you stop what time you
watch which content children tend to
watch in the morning and adults when
they return from work from where you
watch in the world searches for the show
the ratings given browsing and scrolling
behavior and what device you watch is a
program on Netflix uses data science to
show better movie and show
recommendations and the same time
creating better shows for the users
there are 33 million different versions
of Netflix as George's Evers who's the
director of global communications
Netflix at the moment has more than
hundred twenty-five million users
worldwide which means on an average only
four people get the same iteration of
Netflix this is because of all the
personalization that is done to suit the
user's needs or did you also know that
the popular show house of cards was
created completely using data science
and big data this was using the advanced
metrics that I mentioned earlier
Netflix collected user data from another
show called the West Wing from this they
took into consideration where people
rebound a particular scene when they
fast forwarded and when they stopped
watching the show with this they were
able to create what they believed was
perfectly engrossing show data science
is the area of study which involves
extracting knowledge from all the data
that you can gather now that you
understood what data Sciences let's talk
about what a data scientist does we'll
go through all the skills that are
required by a data scientist a data
scientist needs to have the following
several skills database knowledge
statistics programming tools data
wrangling machine learning Big Data
and data visualization let's go one by
one skill number one database knowledge
gaining database knowledge is required
to store and analyze data Oracle
database SQL Server MySQL and Terra data
are some of the tools that are required
for this skill number two statistics
learning statistics probability and
mathematical analysis statistics is the
science concerned with developing and
studying methods for collecting
analyzing interpreting and presenting
empirical data skill number three
programming mastering one programming
language programming tools such as our
Python and SAS are very important to
perform analytics and data R is a free
software environment for statistical
computing and graphics it supports most
machine learning algorithms for data
analytics like regression Association
clustering and so on python is an
open-source general-purpose programming
language and libraries such as numpy in
sci-fi are used in data science SAS can
mine alter manage and retrieve data from
a variety of sources it can also perform
statistical analysis on the data skill
number for data wrangling learning how
to wrangle data up data wrangling
involves cleaning data manipulating data
and organizing the data some of the
tools that are used are arc Python flu
and scoop skill number 5 machine
learning to master the concepts of
machine learning machine learning
provides systems the ability to
automatically learn and improve with
experience without being actually
programmed to do that machine learning
can be achieved through a number of
different algorithms like regression
nave base SVM k-means clustering canaan
decision tree just a name of you skin
number 6 big data having working
knowledge of big data tools big data is
a term that is used to describe large
and complex data it cannot be dealt with
with traditional data processing
software some of the tools that are used
or software's that are used are Apache
spark Hadoop talent tableau Splunk and
so on number seven data visualization to
develop the ability to visualize the
source data visualization involves
integrating different data sets
analyzing models and visualizing them in
the form of diagrams charts and graphs
some of the tools or software's that are
used are tableau click view power bi and
Google Data studio let's talk about some
of the job roles in data science we have
data scientists data engineer data
architect data analysts business
analysts and data administrator let's go
one by one data scientist a data
scientist earns around hundred twenty
thousand US dollars per year and these
are their responsibilities to create
data-driven business
illusions and analytics tribe
optimization and improvement of product
development to use predictive modeling
to increase an optimized customer
experience revenue generation targeting
and so on and coordinating with
different functional teams to implement
models and monitor their outcomes data
engineer a data engineer earns around
130,000 u.s. dollars per year some of
the responsibilities are assembling
large complex data sets to identify
design and implement internal process
improvements to build infrastructure
required for optimal extraction
transformation and loading of data to
build analytics tools that utilize the
data pipeline data architect a data
architect earns at our one hundred and
twelve thousand US dollars per year and
these are their responsibilities to
develop database solutions to install
and configure information systems to
analyze structural requirements for new
software and applications to migrate
data from legacy systems to new
solutions data analyst a data analyst
answer of 65,000 u.s. dollars per year
and these are the responsibilities to
interpret data and analyze results using
statistical techniques to acquire data
from primary or secondary data sources
and maintaining data bases to develop
and maintain data analysis data
collection systems and other SATA G's
working with management to prioritize
business and information needs business
analyst a business analyst earns around
seventy thousand US dollars per year and
these are the responsibilities to assess
the business with planning and
monitoring eliciting and organizing
requirements validating the resource
requirements and developing cost
estimate models creating informaiton
actionable and repeatable reporting data
administrative data administrator earns
around fifty four thousand US dollars
per year and these are the
responsibilities assisting in database
design and updating existing databases
setting up and testing new database and
data handling systems sustaining the
security and integrity of data and
creating complex security definitions
that allow data to be extracted now
let's talk about some of the various
skills that are required for the job
it's very important that a data analyst
has a sound knowledge and programming
tools data visualization communication
and data wrangling a data architect
needs no laudable programming tools
database knowledge statistics
mathematics and linear algebra
Iraida engineer must be good with
programming tools data base knowledge
data wrangling and software engineering
business analyst needs to be got a data
visualization and communication
statistics data wrangling and machine
learning a data administrator needs to
be good with programming tools database
knowledge and it around it now how our
data
scientist needs to be good at
programming tools data visualization
database knowledge statistics data
wrangling and machine learning they also
need to know a good amount of knowledge
on software engineering mathematics and
linear algebra this means you basically
need to know everything about the data
this goes to show that being a data
scientist isn't easy but it also cements
why it is one of the most lucrative jobs
in data science now simply learn also
provide certifications in data science
it provides a data science certification
which is a master's program under this
program we have courses in data science
with SAS training data science
certification training without
programming big data or Dupin SPARC
developer data science with Python
business analytics with Excel machine
learning deep learning with tensor flow
we also have an integrated program in
big data and data science this is also a
master's program the courses that are
covered are data science certification
training with our programming Big Data
Hadoop and spark developer tableau
desktop tend qualified associate
training data science with Python and
machine learning we also have data
science certification courses separately
in python r and SAS now I hope this
video has inspired you to take up a
career as a data scientist I hope you
found this video helpful and informative
thank you for watching this video and
stay tuned for more from simply learn hi
there if you like this video subscribe
to the simple learn YouTube channel and
click here to watch similar videos
turner up and get certified click here